you know i like to think sometimes you
know terminator or something and
despite
despite um
you know
reaching almost total system failure he
keeps trying to accomplish his mission
this was gunman jake davison in despair
last month
police had just given him back his
shotgun and license it's a decision
that's put them under intense scrutiny
certainly in the time that the police
were holding his certificate i would
have expected them to have made very
thorough enquiries and
if they were aware of any of this
information which is now coming to light
suggesting that he's been a deeply
troubled young man for a long time i
cannot imagine they would have given his
certificate back
the home secretary made what her office
said was a private visit to the murder
scene
she spoke to police and residents but
said nothing to journalists
labour leader sakir stama wasn't so
reticent
why did he have a gun license in first
place what were the background checks
that were put in place there's now a lot
of stuff coming about out about the
perpetrator a lot of that will have been
in existence beforehand so a good thing
that the particular issue of the return
of the license is already being
investigated but i think there are wider
questions here about the gun licensing
laws that are going to have to be looked
at how on earth did this come about in
the first place for 12 minutes on
thursday night davison roamed his
neighborhood shooting dead five people
including his mother and a
three-year-old girl then he killed
himself
to get a shotgun license you must show
police you have a good reason for it you
pose no danger and you're medically fit
you're expected to be honest about any
mental health issues
police took back davidson's shotgun for
six months after an allegation of
assault
then returned it
the police watchdog is investigating the
decisions and wants to know what the
force knew of his mental health state
the devon and cornwall police force with
its vast rural landscape and farming
communities has issued around twenty
thousand shotgun licenses
to farmers pest controllers gun club
members
and to a troubled crane operator living
in a city and once accused of assault
martin brunt sky news plymouth